[Music]
all right people were live on the
YouTube
I'm here with now three-time yeah
returning champion to the Rubin report
Tim Poole Tim what's going on a lot I
guess a whole lot there is a lot going
on you are a journalist a man in a
beanie what else what else are the
people who have no idea who the
technologist I did some early pioneering
work with drone technology and in live
News me my buddies did the first live
broadcast of a news report via drone I
helped set up some of the drone test
locations so hacker journalists traveler
weird just jack-of-all-trades I guess I
doing stuff basically yeah yeah so I
think we we sort of cross paths about a
year ago was the first time I had you on
roughly a year ago you were in Milwaukee
yeah during the riots over there and I
had seen a video that you did where you
said it was basically the the most
violent or sort of the scariest place
that you would ever been doing live
reporting from and you've been around
right oh yeah give me some of the places
that you've been to Egypt Ukraine
Venezuela I feel like those are the hot
spots I've been to Ferguson Baltimore a
lot of domestic stuff Thailand Thailand
was was really scary you know the thing
about Milwaukee was that I don't know if
scary is the right word but
disconcerting maybe it's a I felt
genuinely threatened I right I mean you
left because you felt that this thing
was Buuren out of control yeah I mean I
watched a I stood next to a an 18 year
old white kid who got shot in the neck
because he was just why he was even in
the protest he's walking by and these
people are screaming like you know ffu
white boy and things like that and I'm
like I'm I'm mixed-race I'm like Korean
yeah so but it's it's just about
perception do you hold up a sign going
guys and that fully white yeah but it's
you know it's it's weird because if I
agree with the argument of the far-left
they won't call me white they'll they'll
call me mixed and if I question their
opinion not even disagree though Sam is
the white guy yeah you know so with with
you know look in
and they're actually foreign grenades
and people and shooting people and
there's a kind of like constant
alertness that you have when you're like
at any moment I gotta pay attention to
someone chuck in a grenade in our
direction but that's random in Milwaukee
there's these videos where they're
screaming get the white people I hear a
gunshot go off and then sure enough
there's this kid who's not even part of
the protest he just was a few blocks
away walking by and he's holding his
neck and then I watch all these cops
come in with their guns drawn and do
some like SWAT team extraction where
they had to pull him out for no - an
armored vehicle and then I was like this
is getting crazy this is this is nuts so
that's the thing it wasn't even the
specifics of what was going on there
that I thought was interesting but when
I saw although obviously they were there
was interesting things happening it was
that you did this video on why you left
and it seemed like that should have been
a story that reporters and journalists
were under threat were seen crazy but
nobody covered that nobody covered that
I was like wait a minute this guy
actually is doing something different
it was the conservatives who covered it
yeah you know that's what I think nobody
I'm talking about mainstream exactly
stuff there really but it's it's you
know it's the most frustrating thing
when I went to Sweden you know just this
past parents initially the coverage was
favorable to Sweden that I wasn't saying
this crime-ridden neighborhoods and yeah
a bunch of outlets left-leaning and sort
of digital mainstream outlets reported
it saying Tim Poole's trip has Jonas XYZ
I had praise from a lot of progressives
and left saying like haha Tim has proven
the right rung but then the inverse
happened when I encountered some
conflict in the rinkeby neighborhood and
gotten escorted out then the
Conservatives jumped out like ah ha it's
happening and the Liberals they'll have
to live with what the progressive like
left just was totally silent
yeah so it's you know whatever whatever
fits the agenda I suppose yeah so that I
think probably encompasses most of what
we're gonna talk about for the next hour
and then we're into a Q&A after that it
seems to me that everything is breaking
down right now in terms of how we how we
get news how we're treating each other
it does seem worse even in the last
month I think it's somehow gotten worse
and it's been the endless bickering the
you know just picking the sides the
whole thing that everybody knows about
and you're kind of right in the thick of
it because you consider yourself sort of
center-left and I took a test
took the topless test I took the
political compass yeah center-left I'm
sure left libertarian yeah but somehow
you're also in halt right real white
supremacist maniac
I've been called Nazi sympathizer I've
been called white supremacists and I
have a Korean mom yeah so what I saw as
a guy that was in mainstream I know
we've talked about some of this before
but as a guy that was in mainstream you
worked at fusion you work the advice I
mean I get can we consider that
mainstream at this point fusion
absolutely ABC News ID card right big
Disney logo on it yeah I actually did I
did some reporting for ABC News very I
don't even know how it worked but I was
working with ABC out of ABC building
right so so you probably some level of
traditional media you saw some pretty
rotten stuff going on there in terms of
ideology right at fusion yeah yeah yeah
I mean it's like let's just review that
real quick cuz I think so I think it's
important I mean I think I think it all
has to do with business right so I did a
video on sargon of akkad channel what
general he's I'm here later I'll be here
where people people always ask me about
propaganda manipulation and I'm like
look that the reality is that a lot of
these companies are trying to figure out
how to survive and how did what what are
people interested in their businesses
that want to make a product and so at
fusion when I what when I was
negotiating with him when I first
started they were telling me how they
wanted to be like vice oh we want to be
like vice we want to do this cool edgy
new stuff and that's why we need you and
I'm like you got it and then six seven
months later they were like you know
what I think this is not gonna work and
let's start doing social justice you
know far left progressive stuff and
that's when it started just go off the
rails and it's not as you know in my
opinion is there like an actual sit down
where they're like this is what we're
doing now like is it that specific or do
you just kind of get hints that this is
the stuff they're gonna want I just
produce well they move some people
around yeah some some people who had I
don't want to call anybody have but they
had Twitter banner photos saying things
like down with whiteness and they people
they became they gained positions of
power mm-hmm and then it culminated
to where I actually had a meeting with
the president and he said look you know
we're here to side with the audience and
the audience is progressive yeah so you
know and I had I had new
meetings saying like look you know yes
there are a large group of progressive
young people but you will literally cut
your market in half if you just target
one small group and you're not your
company can't survive off of trying to
cater check trying to pander to one
political ideology and they were
convinced the market research tells us
that young people are progressive and
that's what we're gonna do so we can
stay relevant and what happens they lay
off everybody they you know yeah I won't
get too much what happened but yeah it's
so interesting though because I had
Jason Whitlock here a couple weeks ago
from Fox Sports 1 and we were talking
about how ESPN is crumbling and he
totally linked it to them going down the
SJW route of just talking about all of
these things and dividing people amongst
color and sexuality and all that stuff
instead of going to their core brand
proposition which I'm pretty sure sports
yep yeah the way I see it is the squeaky
wheel gets the grease and so you've got
a lot of really loud activists on the
left this is socially acceptable to be a
far left progressive to you can
literally write an article saying Trump
should be executed yeah and people are
like oh okay I'll read that and that's
that's crazy fringe you know the whole
punch a Nazi thing yeah it's it's so
anti-american I don't know it's a weird
thing for me to say being like I grew up
as an anarchist punk rocker and well
look what they're doing to you but free
speech is so important to a free society
and then you actually get the far far
left saying punch of Nazi there's
there's propaganda banners made by the
the anti-fascists where it shows a Nazi
and then it and then on a smaller
picture is it is the same photo but
wearing a trump hat with a knife to his
throat mmm-hmm like these are these are
the things that they're spreading around
and that's socially acceptable yeah
right there's pretty much nothing that's
off the off limits right now right you
could do anything you want really yeah I
think that because you know for whatever
reason when it when a conservative comes
out and says hey man you can't put on a
play where Trump is getting assassinated
then everyone goes oh come on you know
when when for whatever reason the media
I guess because they are they tend to be
left there from mostly the companies are
in big
tend to agree with the left and then
dismisses the the conservative or even
the alternative media viewpoint mm-hmm
it just encourages more and more of this
behavior it's you want to do it then
what happens
yeah is the irony of all this that it
pushes people to people like you to
people like me to oh yeah that are in
the loop with us like I would prefer to
be living in a more stable society where
the things that I care about her are
sort of in action more and then if I was
more irrelevant or had to find another
gig I would go do it gladly
yeah II would I would rather be in that
society but we're not in that society so
then it pushes people to us so there is
like an odd you know dichotomy there you
know I I when I was after I left fusion
and I started talking to a bunch of
companies and found that most of the
digital media companies are pushing this
social justice like I'll say this to I'm
I'm not against social justice right
there's I did a document what would you
do what would you define social justice
as there are legitimate issues in in
society that should be dealt with I
guess I think racism is a real problem
I think sexism is a real problem I think
homophobia transphobia these are all
real things but then when you know me
who's like I'm closer I'm closer to the
middle I look at it like yes these
problems exist and let's take a
reasonable approach to how we solve them
and talk about them and that's but to
the far far left the intersectional
feminist some I'm far right I'm like a
white supremacist so even though I
acknowledge that these problems are real
not to maybe not to the severity that a
lot of these people say it's not good
enough right well that's the thing of
course I acknowledge that racism exists
some people don't like gay people some
people don't like trans people some
people like Muslims some people don't
like Jews some people don't like half
white half Korean people I mean of
course by just because of those words
people don't like it so of course those
things exist but what I'm finding
particularly odd is so in all your
travels have you found a place that is
sort of better on as a whole that's more
mixed and and still better than what
America is like that's what I think was
happening here they're throwing out the
baby with the bathwater oh I'm pretty
sure everywhere I've been has been worse
yeah so is there anything even close
actually when you really think of the
richness of America and all the people
coming here in the melting pot and the
generations of
people of every walk of life literally
from every country on Earth it's it's
relativity you know when you go it's
really funny like Gavin McInnes was
talking like he did he did this video
where he was arguing with this
progressive woman it was kind of like an
ambush where she talked about how the
Scandinavian countries are doing so well
and Gavin goes those countries are more
whiter than America yeah and you know so
you know people often like to use the
Scandinavian countries as like good
examples of and I disagree I'm like the
the things I've heard from even white
people in Sweden are that there's a
there's a cultural divide you know when
they come to the US and you actually
have loud progressive voices who can you
know I don't want to name any I don't
want to name this guy but he goes on
Twitter literally calls everyone a white
supremacist yeah he like a think of
several people oh yeah yeah this guy's
well-known yeah and he any he calls
black women you know wenches and says
they're like you know just these
horrible racist things and it's it's
okay
and I'm like look if if you can get away
with that stuff here like I I definitely
think we have proms with racism
especially in within like the structure
of real estate and and and the economy
for sure but certainly we're like one of
the most progressive places that I've
ever been if the most right that's the
thing I mean I think they believe we can
have some sort of magical utopia that
everyone will be exactly equal which of
course is a the real problem is that
that creates any diversity of thought is
gonna is gonna have to be quashed and
talking to the people that that don't
like us is it too late do you think for
the mainstream media to make a comeback
on this because I'm I'm 50/50 on this
like on one hand I'm enjoying watching
them crumble they've done such you
know CNN is such a shitty job on so many
fronts even the New York Times lately
with headlines that don't really match
what's going on and then forget you know
garbage sites like Mother Jones and the
things that are on the right that are
the equivalent free putting all of those
things aside like I'm enjoying watching
it crumble and then on the other hand if
we have nothing that we can all look to
and basically be like these are that
these are the basic facts yeah then
we're gonna be in a worse situation
we're in now let me tell you story
please do the Washington Post wrote an
article yeah alleging I'm gonna guess a
lot of anonymous
is here huh uh no no no one under the
source is in this one they allege that
kim.com may have been trying to
fabricate an archive of emails to prove
the seth rich conspiracy that's a bold
claim yeah their evidence
Seth Rich's email received a welcome
notification from mega and Xia that's it
and so I read this article and I um I
wouldn't say I'm like an expert in
cybersecurity but I'm a bunch of my
friends are I come from the hacker
community so I'm pretty well-versed and
I look at this article nowhere do they
have any evidence that a hacker from
newzik they said they said a hacker from
New Zealand may have been trying to
access this may no evidence that Kim com
was trying to do this no evidence
kim.com hasn't been involved in mega for
years and simply because their email
account got an email from mega that was
evidence to suggest Kim was trying to
fabricate emails to prove the south rich
conspiracy that is such the that is the
craziest conspiracy theory I have ever
heard published by The Washington Post I
called the report around it mm-hmm I
literally called him on the phone yeah
and I was like how did this happen
there's an this there's you just
literally made this up and he removed a
bunch of the stuff from the article
saying oh I didn't know and so isn't
that so there's a ton of examples of
that we could spend the next day sitting
here just talking about all the years
that have anonymous sources and
allegedly this and you know I love these
people now they're it's like the people
are now policing it which i think is
great so every time one of these
articles comes out watching the
most does a lot of that anonymous
sourcing and know people will start you
know screen capturing it and
highlighting every word that allegedly
source friend unnamed you know like all
these things and then you by the time
you get to all of that you're like this
is literally made up so that is the
beauty of the Internet that now the
people are police big we've given up on
them policing themselves it's it's it's
waltz pros and cons that we have to we
have the police we have to do the stuff
the scariest thing to me is that when
I've called out some of this journalism
I get responses from big-name
journalists saying Tim this is
journalism 101 like I don't
again I don't wanna call anybody but I
have I mean there's that those practices
of the anonymous source and the diss
yeah and so what I've realized is
there's a divide between what is
acceptable to the Internet community
rank pics or it didn't happen
versus the journalism community where
they say just trust us don't trust the
fake news but trust us right which I do
not trust them I mean anybody right so
they so they need us to buy into their
sort of old-school narrative because
otherwise it crumbles pretty quickly so
I guess that's why it's happening right
yeah so what's getting scary to me is
that I did a video about Britney
Pettibone who is you know she's one of
the Trump supporting you know American
nationalists she calls herself someone
notified me that on her Wikipedia page
they were discussing me in the talk
section right so anybody can edit
Wikipedia the talk section is where they
decide how to make edits and in her
article it claimed that she was a
contributor to alt-right comm which is
Richard Spencer's website in she told me
in two interviews that she was not a
contributor there never was yeah
so in the talk section someone's asking
hey a video interview she did with Tim
Poole says you know she claims she's
never contributed there should we use
this as a reliable source and they said
Tim Poole is not a reliable source his
his content is an opinion and I and I
read this and I'm like how was an
interview that I did with someone
telling me outright they've never been a
contributor yeah and then you can
actually go to the website alright calm
and see she's never been a contributor
how was it not a reliable source when I
worked for a vice infusion the work I
did was a reliable so yeah and there's
literally no difference in the work I'm
doing now to the work I was doing then
there's no editor who like reads my
content and then fact checks it wasn't
it vice you could kind of say that I
guess because we had a different some
producers who would go over the script
and like look at documentary stuff
fusion I would just you know I'd produce
I ran my own team and that's all
acceptable why because I have a big
brand backing me and so I I was talking
to someone who was working with a
volunteer with Wikimedia and I said if I
start a brand name and publish under
that you'll consider that a reliable
source but simply because I'm an
independent journalist on YouTube my
content is seeming is no longer factual
what ends up happening is these fake
news articles become sources yeah
for wikipedia articles and what ended up
happening with Brittany Pettibone is
they looked at the citation claiming she
was a contributor at this website her
name wasn't even in the article but that
was good enough for Cappy dia yeah yet
my interview was not good enough so what
does that tell you about Wikipedia cuz
I've also you look I think a couple
years ago Wikipedia was providing some
sort of value and I see it now as really
it's turned because because of the exact
reasons you're talking about there's so
much fakeness out there you know even
you know you gave me a very hearty
defense which I thank you for before and
I'll thank you for again yesterday over
this nonsense that happened with me and
Mother Jones claiming I was you know but
in effect in all right excuse but like
that could then get into Wikipedia
and then what then I have to try to get
into my own Wikipedia defended or hope
that somebody like you can just all
garbage that this is exactly why I came
to your defense yeah I don't want to say
I came to your defense I come to my
defense I believe in rational
self-interest then yeah well for you
then that's my only uh but but you know
I I the same thing happened to me just a
week or so ago where look in 2011 I
literally slept at Occupy Wall Street
for months if I wasn't in the park I was
at one of the occupiers homes or
apartments or a volunteer and I was just
there to experience and learn I'm you
know like I said I'm like kind of center
center left and so I wasn't really
strong all the political stuff but I
wanted to see what was going on and they
call that great journalism my god Tim
it's an immersion journalism he went on
the ground and actually worked with
these people yeah and then I go to
dinner with Trump supporters and you've
crossed the line that's unethical you're
all right you're all right chill so this
news this outlet and again I don't know
I don't wanna drive any traffic to their
site called me an alt right journalist
and they put journalists in quotes
mm-hmm so I call them and I you know I
get on the phone with like one of their
editors or something and I said I don't
know why you put journalists in quotes
is that a dig at me or something like no
no no we assure you it's not I'm like oh
come on right there so okay so so that
happens to you this nonsense happens to
me even I mentioned on my direct message
this morning last week Forbes called
this a conservative talk show which they
immediately they actually immediately
retracted and I don't think conservative
is a PR
but to say this is a conservative talk
show I'm just talking to people so if
they had called I guess if they had said
this is a classic a classic talk show
hosted by a class of a liberal that
would be the the true definition but
just putting these words in to help
everybody pre think you know what what
the truth is I think is they want to
they want to put you in a box so that
people immediately make an assumption
about what you are before they even
watch what you do
yeah so what do we do to fight this
monster so you know I went on the
full-on attack yeah yeah I Unleashed and
my got tens of thousands I see all
these people attacking I was like of it
I was like I'm just not going to this
guy that wrote this piece he was one of
the 40 people that the Virginia baseball
game shooter followed on Twitter now we
know this guy was a was a far lefty and
clearly had been at least at some level
radicalized by some of the things he was
reading so when you call me an extremist
to the further of the right of right
Bart there's there's an actual implicit
danger in there did you forgetting that
it's not true you know to be putting
that aside did you hear that a trump
supporter was just stabbed nine times
the other day here in LA I didn't hear
that actually this guy Tony who I've
actually met and talked with he's the
bodyguard for Baked Alaska and so these
you know Baked Alaska has been
controversial yeah because he's you know
one of the alright guys I suppose this
guy Tony isn't a public figure or
anything but he was leaving a bar he was
driving away in a car rear-ended him
this is their story
yeah he said that a car rear-ended him
and when he got him to exchange
information they said you're getting the
shank white boy stabbed him nine times
geez he got 12 hours of surgery he's
still in UCLA awaiting another surgery I
believe so when an outlet a news outlet
says that I'm an alt right the other
knows the alt right that's Richard
Spencer yeah those are white
nationalists that's dangerous yeah when
people are writing about stabbing and
punching Nazis and then you hear some
guy for his political beliefs got
rear-ended and then stabbed multiple
times these journalists are creating an
extreme danger especially for me mmm
because I have to go on the ground to
these places I was just in San
Bernardino and one of the anti anti fog
eyes you know he took a swing at me yeah
he was trying to take my hat decide I
don't make it seem like you're in the
face yeah but a lot of questions about
your hat
by the way a lot of people wanted to
know more about that but well it's like
it's it's an escalation and people
getting physical with me in Portland I
had I got one guy followed me around for
hours screaming my name and screaming
you know fu and then he would proud
other people like hey that's Tim pool
while I'm walking around just trying to
film things and I had to and he was
following my livestream to see where I
was at mm-hmm the police wouldn't do
anything about it and then later on I
had another guy doing this if you're
gonna write an article falsely accusing
me of being alright and then and then I
have to go to it they're gonna make it
so that I can't do my job
anymore yeah but but even beyond that
they're gonna make it so that you can't
live anymore I I don't mean that
someone's gonna come kill you but I mean
I was even thinking on Friday after this
thing went down so a certain amount of
people suddenly saw this article and now
will think Dave Reubens extremist to the
right Weber aye aye took a couple
flights over the last few days and I was
even thinking when I was at the airport
I was like anybody could have just read
this thing now see me and when they're
telling you you're an extremist right
but what they're saying is that I
they're saying I'm somehow some evil
racist which is the furthest thing from
the truth
and that bit so they are putting a
target on your head for it's just
somebody to come up to me at an airport
and just smash a wineglass over
my head or for associating for
interviewing yeah people he came by the
way in the article I mean yeah I know
you know this but I mean he came up with
three interviews of mine he didn't like
so it was CERN in a Milo and I
think the southern forgetting all the
progressives I've interviewed that most
of my interviews have been with people
that I think are really liberal to
libertarian but all that it just doesn't
matter because he knows he's gay all he
has public shame now because I destroyed
this guy but he knows he's not losing
his job because the editor who he
included on a zillion of these Suites
she's not gonna say but here's the thing
you know to the people who know you to
the people who are friends or the people
who know you yeah you you may have you
know cause some damage for this guy the
far-left progressives are cheering him
on right there cheering they're like
good job you know you you you show you
show Dave so what's your process okay so
you when these things happen to you
you've tried you call people email
people well here's here's a funny thing
when they got when this news outlet did
this they apologized to me
they said that wasn't supposed to be in
there I'm so sorry well we'll remove
that we're gonna change it to news
producer and I was like okay and they're
like our editors adamant about not
calling you a journalist something along
those lines that it wasn't
you should have been I'm adamant about
your editor not calling yourself an
editor yeah but you know what honestly
we know I was thinking I was like they
want to call me a news producer I'm like
I don't have any citations that claim
that I'm a producer as well so I'll take
it
sure I've got I got a war I've got an
award in journalism I've got accolades
from some foundations for my working
journalism but as a digit as a media
producer in a news producer yeah I could
use a citation that says that what do
you think about that Streisand effect
with all this that by fighting back you
then amplify them because I did have
before I went on the assault I had a
one-minute debate in my head it was
going back up real quick and the angry I
just took over and I'm glad I did it
that way but there's another piece that
it's like these things are always gonna
come and the more you fight them you're
as you're saying it shows those people
ah you see you can get to them yeah
let's just amplify let's get more
sockpuppet accounts attacking and this
guy gained followers yeah you know
because he's got hate followers now and
progressive followers who like him it's
a challenge it's the Streisand effect
III know feminists who always retweet
trolls and I'm like that's what they're
trying to get you to do yeah that's exam
but they're not every situation is the
same I think in your case the reason it
was important for you to come out and
challenge this article was so that in
the future if there's ever a question
about whether or not you are far-right
you have a huge tirade saying like I do
not stand for this yeah if you let it
slide to try and avoid the Streisand
effect they'd be like well the article
came out Dave didn't say anything yeah
and by the way just to show at every
level what a fraud this guy is he then
did tweet at me not publicly I don't
believe you're further to the right than
Breitbart
yeah it's basically it but his pin tweet
include which is the article that I'm
included in is still talking about the
extremists yes further to the right and
at the same time he's going after my
patreon money because that's what
they're you know he linked the whole
thing to patreon is tolerant of these
evil people so it's like yes you're not
a journalist your key is not this is not
a journalist this is an active activist
yep this is an activist right this is
why tweeted while I said I'm I'm
formally requesting that media
organizations stop hiring activists and
start hiring journalists mmm and it got
thousands of retweets
now if I worked for these companies yeah
I know what they do it's like I could
name if I were to name every journalist
who was actually an activist
I couldn't count them on my hands in my
daughter they're there people who appear
on you know Fox News well who on these
shows and they say have journalists in
their title and you read their stuff and
it's like either they're willfully
ignorant or they're malicious I there's
no way that somebody's gonna have two
hundred thousand followers be following
this stuff wholeheartedly and not know
that what they're saying isn't true yeah
this this guy come on
he knows who you are no he put you in
front of Serna vich and Baked Alaska and
Kyle Chapman in front of these names in
an article about extremists and I read
that I'm like he you know you know it
really makes me angry about this is that
he can then dance around saying oh but I
corrected it no the article is about
extremists and you put Dave in that and
you're yeah I think you're left of me
yeah you know but right he can write in
the article so in the article about me
oh sure they write that okay they
removed all right but they still wrote
an article about the far-right going to
this restaurant and meaning together and
then and wrote a piece about me trying
to hide from the camera which was not
true at all yeah and then put that I was
sympathetic to Trump and his supporters
and stuff like that which is I'm like
sure I told the guy on the phone you
want to say I'm sympathetic to the Trump
supporters at the rallies just don't
forget to mention that I've been
sympathetic to black lives matter and to
refugees as well go to my youtube
channel right right up in front of the
documentary about refugees no it doesn't
he said okay yeah well I think we're
gonna keep it I like that you said
before that you that you didn't do it to
defend me what did you say you didn't do
it to defend a defender for me is to
defend yourself and and I I love that
because I really believe that's the
truth anyone that defended me if you're
defending me yeah I appreciate your
defense but I like that it you were
defending yourself because it's the same
monster I've been saying this for years
now the same monster that originally
went after Sam Harris and said he was a
llama folk that takes that attacks you
know has the Southern Poverty Law Center
saying that ayaan Hirsi Ali is an anti
Muslim extremist this same insane
monster is coming for everybody so I
don't so you could have been like you
know what Dave Rubin I don't care
about him but I'm gonna defend myself
here well you know it's kind of a
beautiful thing actually you know the
saying is first they came for the yeah
Communists and yeah I mean look you know
I this is
third time I've come out on your show it
there's been this weird argument about
whether or not left and right means
policy anymore does mean social justice
mhm and now we're looking at simply
limit later stop there let me say this
yeah why do i why do i interview Trump
supporters well I want to better
understand where their perspective comes
from and help really like that's the
point
you know journalism in my opinion that's
all you're saying they're humans they're
actually human I found out that the
Trump supporters they're actually people
well you know I yeah many people thought
that they were some kind of like demon
or crazy monster but now I know what the
promo is for this episode yeah yeah but
there are there human beings who come
from a place that gives them a certain
perspective and if I'm going to either
convince them of what I think is right
or just even help someone else better
understand them I'm gonna go hang out
and talk to them and have chicken wings
and and ask them questions and debate
them and that's too much that's that's
that's you know you you are officially
one of the monsters now just by that the
point is the only way to really mend the
political divide stop the violence is to
have honest conversations with everybody
the the media so often attacks people
like now it's it's attacking you and in
fact I just uh later I did a video with
Chris Reagan I interviewed him about
this he made a video called punch a Nazi
it's a music video I thought yeah it's
great and in it he talks about how if
you like the one of the first lines is
if you don't constantly criticize the
president euro white supremacists and
then sure enough just you know people
start calling him a white supremacist
yeah I'm like yeah III asked whether you
made a video about this then sure enough
they started doing it too you know it's
it's like the irony is lost on these
people do you think at any level they
realize what they're actually
accomplishing so I get it they're
they're getting a certain amount of
clicks they're getting this this virtue
signaling feel they feel really good
about what they're doing but do you
think they realize the amount of people
they're pushing away at the same time
because I see that number max look I
know the numbers of what we're doing
here I know the amount of emails I get
from literally all over the world so do
you think they have any sense of what
the counter movement that they've
started that I think people have know I
picked up on yet but I know it's here
it's not some of these people working
there probably figured it out but I
think anybody who's at these big
companies and has seen this has moved on
already I mean I were just
for two years afterwards I had a bunch
of meetings with these digital companies
and after these meetings I decided I
can't work for them because I can see
what's going to happen in the next
several years sure there's a possibility
that it goes the wrong it goes crazy and
this progressive stuff just really
dominates forever but in my opinion I
think we're on the back end of the bell
curve that things are starting to wind
down we're starting to see less of this
mm-hmm
you know fusion basically so does that
explain why there's more hysteria then
like the hysteria is getting louder but
because it act because we are actually
on that other side it's it's yeah it's
like the volume is decreasing so to make
up for it they're trying harder and
harder mm-hmm and it's it's like what
kind of this is my opinion look I I've
argued of people about this but I think
we're starting to become desensitized
we're getting to the point where young
people are just tired of being called
white supremacist racist and there's
going what I don't even care anymore
just get away from Emma talking to you
yeah so you gotta scream louder yeah to
get the same it's like it's like a it's
like an addiction you need more heroin
to get your high doesn't that that whole
episode at Evergreen State which you
were gonna go to but then you you ended
up not going to it was it was cancelled
for like another few days and so I was
just like yeah right yeah I was gonna I
was at in Portland so yeah but doesn't
that whole episode show you the the true
essence of the flaw here in in this
thinking which is that this place is the
most left it might be literally the most
left progressive campus in America quite
possibly and if they're dealing with all
of this evil racism and yeah yeah hell
via and what does that say about what
they've created there this is this is
all of their values are there in you
know amplified to the nth degree and yet
they're dealing with this stuff and but
the point is well they'll take a guy
like Brett Weinstein who's they need to
find racism so you find a guy who's
anti-racist and you and you pin him as a
racist it's uh cannibalism they've been
so many people on the Left I've been
fighting themselves you know they hear a
lot of I tweeted about this a bunch of
my lefty friends were like come on you
can't say that but what I said was it
was during the the anti Sharia stuff
that was happening across the country
seeing so many people on the Left jumped
in the defense of a religion was it was
interesting to me because yeah and their
immediate responses it's about religious
freedom and I'm like just a couple years
ago those are religious
freedom bill that you guys were saying
was was a trick to take away the rights
of the LGBT community and I'm not saying
it is we're isn't but I'm just looking
for some consistency I suppose I've
talked a lot of people who told me
feminism makes sense
there are historically women have been
kind of held back even in most most
countries today women are in serious
jeopardy there's a lot of countries that
are horrifying but then when feminism
starts encompassing other ideas like
defending Islam yeah
in my opinion like do your religion by
all means you you know but feminism is a
femme literally means like female yeah
and it's about the rights of women
specifically so I've had people tell me
that they just sort of lost interest
when it started fighting for the rights
of religions and other communities that
didn't fit with what the problems women
are facing were yeah so it's so is that
that is that the silver lining here is
that intersectionality it has to destroy
itself I want more people to understand
that that we have to expose it but it
will destroy itself because these groups
have competing interests yes yes like it
my ultimately like I said you know I I'm
I'm not anti social justice I'm not anti
feminists no I agree with a lot of the
things for me to say with a lot of
things like a lot of stuff the
anti-racist a like I was my family's
been victims of racism of racist attacks
and things like that but what's that
what ends up happening is if you have a
group of people that say look my core
interest is fighting for the rights of
women then you come to them say but you
have to fight for the rights of this
other group too they're gonna say I'm
not interested in that so it's not about
what whether or not fighting for the
rights of these groups are right or
wrong or what these groups do or right
or wrong
simply that trying to create this like
global alliance of marginalized voices
creates competing factions within that
group and then what ends up happening
they fight each other they leave there's
there's a large amount of infighting
that goes on amongst a lot of these
progressive right now especially if you
look at Laci green mm-hmm who simply
came out and said I want to have a
conversation with the anti-feminists -
you know better understand them and what
happens death threats daxing you know
conqueror fascist
yeah it's a you you can't come out and
even want to have a conversation yeah
well I was happy to see that Laci who I
don't even know cain't you know she's
coming on the show next month
we've talked Lou it but she came to my
public defense and it's like
in a way it's her defending herself
which is which is kind of a beautiful
thing
I'm curious it's a slight sidebar but
where do you think your commitment to
honesty comes from because my own
detriment no we were I feel the same way
like I'm look I tell people what I think
I never pretended to have all the
answers I will screw up things there's
there's been episodes where I've made
mistakes that we don't edit it out
because I want people like I've made
some pretty stupid mistakes that we
don't edit out because I want people to
see that that I can make mistakes and I
and I've said that the most teachable
moment in the three years that we've
been doing this is when I had Larry
elder on and I was going on about
systemic racism and he challenged me not
denying that racism itself doesn't exist
but he kind of beat me over the head
with numbers and facts and it was it
changed how I thought of things we could
edited that out it didn't make me look
good as i sat there kind of browbeat em
you know does make you look good it's so
I guess that you're you're willing to
learn and and progress and make yourself
better yeah why is that so rare these
days that's why you now or I think the
second three time guess not because I
just found you and I was like wait a
minute
this guy seems to care about something
true you know to me I didn't know
exactly what I still don't know fully
well you're polluted I don't know if
you're pro-choice or pro-life or you
know or what you feelings are on taxes
or I'm just anti-authoritarian yeah okay
like I I grew up with a bunch of
anarchists and you know if you have an
authoritarian regime you can make a lot
of things happen but man life would just
sure suck so when it comes to a lot of
policy stuff ultimately I'm like well
can you force someone to do it like I'm
not cool with with I don't subscribe to
the belief that people are so stupid yet
to tell them how to live their lives and
I think that the the point of life and
and and what works is competing ideas
and the best ideas rise to the top so we
don't need to say I'm right therefore I
have the right to bash you over the head
with a bike lock and make my ideas right
yeah you know when I go to these rallies
the reason I'm willing to be completely
honest and say here's what happened the
Trump side here's it happen with the
left side is because I don't I don't
care who's right I care what is right
yeah
if we want to live in the best
world then we should find out what is
correct and then use that data honestly
I think it has to do with coming from
like the hacker community and being kind
of a science oriented person to where
the web described is in the past is
other people call me a journalist I've
sort of just used that because it people
understand it but what I really try to
do is collect as much accurate data as
possible so that I can better understand
why these things are occurring know the
best way to do this to go on the ground
talk to people collect research and then
come to determination on how we move
forward unfortunately a lot of
journalists and a lot of other people
are ideologically driven they say I know
the world should be this way I'm gonna
find evidence to back that up
it's like these political factions are
replacing religion almost yeah it's so
interesting because I don't people will
tweet me and say you know Dave you're
one of the few journalists I trust I
don't consider myself a journalist I say
I sit in this room and talk to people
yeah I hear what they say sometimes they
say things that I think you're nuts but
I let them say it and sometimes they
don't I think the best example I can
give I had the you know Bishop Baron
here from the archdiocese in LA this guy
does not believe in gay marriage because
that's what the terminating 7 people
were I really challenged him a lot he
got a lot of hate from Christian
websites because I got him basically to
say that his head is and his heart don't
quite match up I thought that was pretty
impressive by letting him talk he he
eventually got to that place so they
were giving him a lot of things
that were you know Christian
conservative we're saying wait did he
just endorse gay marriage but I thought
the people that were angry at me were
like well you sat there with him and Bob
up and it's like do you think I was
gonna get a bishop in here and then by
the end of it he was gonna be like you
know what here's the frock and yeah yeah
you know it's over hold on let me let me
better we're saying is that you had a
religious person said in this chair who
was a post gay marriage crazy so you
yourself are opposed to gay marriage
that means right obviously those
articles are gonna start coming out yeah
Dave Rubin opposes gay marriage that'll
be in every Union Wikipedia yeah but
this monster it's coming for everybody I
mean that's what my direct message was
about this morning like yeah you don't
fight it it will come whatever you think
whatever you think that it's not group
think they'll figure out a way to pin
you on it's like I mean we have more
than enough movies about the
post-apocalyptic future where ideas are
restricted there's a one of my
whose equilibrium they've ever seen that
no like all forms of art and emotion
have been suppressed and there's like
people who have paintings like hidden
underground they're being killed like I
mean that Fahrenheit 451 people you know
I've actually never read it but there
was a bunch of posts about it being
about how our society gets so offended
we decide to start self censoring and
destroying books because it would offend
oh this one we've had will offend unions
this one will offend cat lovers we can't
offend people so let's just destroy it
all that's that's what scares me
yeah the homogenous ation of ideas leads
to a very bad place it's it's also it's
it's almost like when you look at
evolution by genetic diversity helps a
species survive and if you homogenized
all of that and then so I'll put it this
way let's say there's like ten political
factions and they're all competing with
each other and they all have an answer
to a certain problem that they we we may
or may not face if you get rid of all
but one that can't answer the problems
in the future and we're doomed it's over
so is the inherent problem that we have
if we take those ten competing things it
they all want to live in very different
societies no no right so my belief is
because we live in a pluralistic society
300 million people it's like well we
have we have a set of laws here we have
a constitution and we have to live by
that we have to do it's a pretty damn
great document I think we have to live
by that but we have people that actually
want to alter that or scrap that like so
we're debate now is not you know how do
we modify laws or how do we grow or
shrink government it's like are we gonna
just rip up the whole damn thing amend
it to death right you know I'm really
impressed with the American system
because I've been around the world and
I've when I think back you know is my
opinion but I'm like I think the
founding fathers of the United States
had it had a pretty good idea it's the
three branches they're basically three
different kinds of government competing
with each other to in extents checking
each other out and you look at other
governments it's like just a king just
or just a despot just a parliamentary
system and we have different systems
you know we have Congress and the
representatives Senate in Congress who
are like you know the council a that's
the democracy then you have the
president who's the executive authority
and and that council of elders the the
judicial branch and they all make sure
each other doesn't step out of line then
I look at how far we've come
even progressively in the United States
and I'm like yeah this country's done a
pretty good job right it's got a lot of
problems for sure that's the thing it's
like we're such a young country too in
the scheme of things you know compared
to most of our Western and European
allies we're so young we we've moved so
far and yet people want to just view all
the terrible things and I I you know I
think it's perception is reality is this
the same and when I look at like this
progressive stuff when I look at how
people hate America and and I I guess I
look at it like if you were in the civil
rights movement you told your kids this
stuff was terrible and always remember
we need to fight for our civil rights
these kids grow up in a world where
they're significantly less racism and
sexism still exists and then so they
keep fighting it they tell their kids
the same thing you need to fight sexism
racism homophobia but now the younger
generation is growing up in the United
States where although these problems
exist it's significantly less but
they're fighting this as hard as as the
past generations so how do you how do
you fight a fight when oh you you tell
someone that their hairstyle is
appropriating someone's culture and they
should cut their hair feminists arguing
about you know video games and things
like that instead of you know you look
over to countries like Saudi Arabia
can't drive other horrifying things very
equal with video game representation
wouldn't you say yeah and I know like I
said as argument people say look we're
there's they're different problems to be
fought and some people if you're gonna
fight the problems here but it's not
it's not to say that they shouldn't
fight but it's simply like we've come to
a point where what we have to argue
about is like video games pretty good
that's pretty sweet
yeah it's that's not bad are there
problems oh hell yeah that need to be
fixed definitely but I kind of think we
need to take a point of perspective
perspective climb up on a mountain look
down
everything and say wow you know we got
problems but damn we've done a good job
yeah so you've mentioned the hacker
community yeah helpful times so I'm
actually not that familiar with the
hacker community and you've said it kind
of framed a little bit of why you care
about truth and all that can you tell me
a little bit I mean so in the hacker
world there's what is a hacker for like
really let's just do like 101 justice
hacker is someone who makes something do
something it was not intended to do
that's simple so if you take that if you
took that bottle of water and use it as
a paperweight you are hacking it it's a
really great rude way to describe it but
you know the word sort of been changed
by like the mainstream I suppose right
but you you end up with a bunch of
subsets of that so most people think
hackers are out computer hackers are
trying to steal your information
that's not sure I think actually most
hackers are people who build little
robots who will take apart a doorknob
and then make a piece of art with it
they have hacker spaces all over the
world where you pay a membership fee you
can go in and use a bunch of tools and
what do you see it's a bunch of hippie
dudes who make like neon lights for
Burning Man right you know but then the
computer hackers are in there too a
computer hacker someone who can make a
computer do something it wasn't intended
to do that so within that another subset
is the InfoSec Information Security
mm-hmm so I I used to program video
games I see do graphic design websites I
still do graphic design a website stuff
and I grew up with these people one of
the core tenants that is it's not
Universal obviously nothing's absolute
is the freedom of information during you
know if you look like Kim calm and
megaupload there's the church of copán
ism which is piracy like sharing digital
files that information should be free
you see groups like WikiLeaks Julian
Assange was the hacker mendax
who did a bunny I think I don't remember
what he did but if the hack to NASA or
something and and now he's you know
running WikiLeaks yeah you had Aaron
Swartz the these people all believe in
the freedom of information and that's
something that I believed in too is that
we want to collect as much information
as possible and then share that so we
can all better understand the world yeah
I started doing what I do not because I
want to be a journalist I can go to
school for this but because my hacker
buddies in LA
we're doing work in the Arab Spring and
I was you know we were sitting down
discussing ways we could help the
activists get information out because
the government's trying to silence some
of things like that and we believe that
everyone has a right to know what's
happening so I said I'm not gonna
program anything I'm not gonna set up a
satellite or anything I can't just go on
the ground and start taking pictures and
and sharing that and that'll go back to
the the IRC the hacker chat rooms and
we're with my hacker buddies in that way
and then the the greater public took
notice and then I'll send I'm a
journalist yeah so for me it's it's not
about journalistic ethics or its like
that it's literally about the freedom of
information obviously I'm not a freedom
of information absolutist yeah that was
my next question do you think
governments have any right to have any
secrets yes not to a great degree
right I'm anti authoritarian I'm very
very close
four people are familiar the compass
it's like authoritarian libertarian left
and right yeah and I'm pretty close to
the bottom yeah but I think it would be
ignorant to be like you know there are
some things that if you know if your mom
said do I look does this dress make me
look gross and you're like hey mom
you're disgusting you know so there are
some instances where it's it's it's not
like like nuclear codes yeah right some
discretion over you know ciphered agents
I think were we're in a we're in a world
with competing factions with competing
cultures and some cultures most cultures
don't like each other you know we're
tolerant of each other but there are
some cultures in this planet they're
really like we will kill you mm-hm and
so if we've just published all of our
secrets
we probably die yeah you know it very
bad stuff would happen to us so you know
when I see the the argument from the
government to pelacone leaking our
secrets are bad and all that stuff it it
depends really if you look at the
instance of reality winner this woman
who leaked the the Russian hacking you
know it was actually a UH the suspicions
of the NSA I don't I don't think there's
any proof but the NSA is saying they
believe this is what happened that's not
whistleblowing that's just leaking
information mm-hmm whistle blowing I'm
for if the US government to say killing
American citizens abroad which they've
done
and someone wants to blow the whistle on
that that's where we get good so what if
there are just a cascade of unintended
consequences I'm basically with you on
whistle blowing I believe we have to
know some of these things because their
machine has gotten too big and I'm an
authority as well but what about the
unintended consequences of that where
you you could leak something that then
could put all sorts of humans at risk
you think that you know sorta density of
it the main reason why I am NOT an
activist is that I just don't think I'm
smart enough to actually address those
problems so I figured I'm not gonna go
on the street and we have a flag saying
we should have you know freedom of
information absolutism everything should
be should be 100% open and available to
everybody I'm looking there's probably
so much I don't know that I think what
I'll do is I'll just personally work to
do what I can to have free information
open where where I see it and I can do
that on the ground covering big events
around the world when it comes what the
government's are doing I just don't know
enough about what the consequences would
be to it so it's it's like it's
imagining the scenario where someone
feels hey if I you know shut down this
dam which is causing environmental
destruction I'll save the planet and
then they end up destroying a city or
something it's like I don't want to be
the one that pulls that lever right you
know do you think it's kind of odd that
at some level you're you talk about
politics a lot because you don't strike
me as particularly political actually
like at all every all of this leads to
you having to talk about politics but
it's not like like again we can we can
knock it all out if you want but I
really don't know most of your your
straight-up political beliefs this is as
funny as that right right
right no I I've never I don't tweet
about social justice for or against it I
just worry about what's happening
most of this stuff where I'm opinionated
is like criticisms of the media yeah and
that's basically it so it was crazy
because when when this when this news
outlet said that I was all right I'm
like I got my Twitter and literally I'm
like my last tweet was like what's your
favorite song and then below that it was
like what's your favorite place to be
and I'm and then and then below that was
like criticisms of media and I'm like I
don't have I never talked about black
lives matter I never talked about Islam
directly I've done like one video
recently it's like I'm being
forced to address these things but I
usually my my pins in the matter are
usually like I I guess I should say this
when people ask me like how do you feel
about this issue where that issue how do
you feel about Islam how do you feel I'm
like freedom of expression
anti-authority and ultimately I just
don't know so what can I do I can read
the data and then show you the data that
I found I can go on the ground and talk
to people and tell you what they said
right so then but through that often
through looking at at data through
talking to people you're often gonna
come to the conclusions that are the
unpopular ones these at least at the
moment right now with something like
Islam for example if you were to look at
the data and and talk to a lot of the
people and just look at pupils well it's
gonna get you to come to some
conclusions that a lot of people are not
gonna be happy well here's the
interesting thing what did I learn about
Sweden well it's not a crime-ridden
refugee hellhole like the far-right keep
saying but it's also not a utopia like
the leftist thing our refugees causing
crime in Sweden yes a small minority of
them but the crimes are atrocious
they're more fiying sex crimes are they
seeing crimes in certain neighborhoods
they call no-go zones yes but those are
the children of immigrants and that is
likely due to failed immigration
policies 20 years ago so everyone's
wrong yeah everyone's a little right I
was a little wrong well that's the funny
thing do on Sweden is such an
interesting example because I've had
several people from Sweden on the show
to talk about this and they've all
acknowledged that but they were not
Islamophobic bigots they were all
acknowledging that the the integration
problems and some of the the robust
social services that they gave
eventually caused these people to be
stuck in enclaves you know it's like
they weren't blaming this all on
religion it doesn't mean there's no
religious component but even try and
explain that to people so here's the
unpopular opinion that here's what
happens when I talk to a conservative
like I all sit down for dinner
with Trump supporters and yeah and we'll
argue this and I'll tell them look man
when you when you bring it a bunch of
refugees and then you put them in an
enclave where they have no access to the
actual greater community they can't
speak the language they can't find work
what are they gonna do learn to start
building their own means and it's gonna
create a system within the system and
then these young kids what's happening
in in Sweden these kids are growing up
as Swedish citizens but they're called
immigrants by people in Sweden
and then when they go back to their home
country to see their grandparents
they're called Swedish they don't fit in
with either culture so what do they do
well they can't get jobs because they're
not Swedish they're immigrants to the
people there what can they do they can
make me join gangs they steal they they
they just try and figure it out but it
makes them resentful of the greater
system make some disrespectful of it and
so what needs to be said is are there
neighborhoods
and it's not just Sweden but like the US
has similar issues are there are there
issues of racism that hold back as
communities yes it's culturalism it's
racism at the same time are this
community is committing crime in these
areas yes like the two things are
happening so when you've had those
conversations with Trump supporters at
dinner do you think they're a little
more amenable to those ideas because I
do see a difference right now I just do
between trying to build the bridge and
have sensible conversations with people
that are this far left thing where I
think you can break through to some
conservatives on that I know here's I've
done it right here here's where I think
we sort of a lose perspective you
familiar with the Overton Window of
course but I waited for it yeah
basically the Overton Window is it's
like a scale of what's socially
acceptable to what's not right in the
middle it's a reverie what talks about
and the further you know up or down you
go it gets less and less acceptable yeah
take the political compass and put the
overt you put a you know a
two-dimensional Overton what you know
Overton Window right in the middle of
what is socially acceptable and the
fringe areas of the compass are they
shouldn't be socially acceptable but the
over tomatoes moved so far to the left
that the fringe left as far as you go
left is socially acceptable when we talk
about Trump supporters being you willing
to have a conversation we're talking
about center-right to right-wing people
who are not fringe extremists know that
I'm sitting down with I'm not talking
about white nashit like I've talked to
white nationalists right they are not
having conversations right but we've in
the way the window has I did it makes
its at when you say Trump supporter
people think that I need to correct that
they're having conversations but they're
not moving so I actually spoke with guys
they call themselves a race realists and
they flat out said IQ race they're all
intertwined white people Jewish people
there's so much smarter asian people
therefore
you know yadda yadda and I said I think
you're overlooking culture and they said
you're wrong you're wrong you're a
liberal you're wrong but at least you
know they're like but we'll talk to you
about it mm-hmm
when you talk when you look at the left
I mean you're left I'm left we're like
I'm Center left even Laci green is is
pretty far left and she's willing to
have conversations and check facts and
and I think most people have realized
that with the video she's made recently
but when you go to the fringe left yeah
they're not gonna listen they're gonna
say punch in Nazi so we start to say
things like except that's not just
fringe left because when that thing
happened to Richard Spencer I saw all
sorts of mainstream verified people on
Twitter celebrities movie stars
comedians all saying it was the right
thing to do so I think that's what you
mean by the window shifting right it
went exactly it's becoming more and more
socially acceptable to be further and
further left yeah so people say things
like you think Trump supporters are more
willing to have conversation stuff like
that I say yes but it's only because a
lot of the Trump people aren't far-right
extremists like the media says they are
mm-hmm this is the craziest thing when
they criticized you for saying that some
of these people were centrist I'm like
come on you're Fairbanks for example
yeah she's considered they called her
for at far right numerous times yeah she
took the political spectrum test and
she's just sent her right eye I've
exchanged stuff with her on Twitter I
met her once first off totally lovely
girl like we had a great night we got
drunk in DC was she knows everybody we
had a great time and she was going on
and on about why she supported Bernie at
first yes so it's like but no now she's
racist too she's she's got a bunch of
like nationalistic views but she's not
but far right and the truth like the
actual sense of like economy and
authoritarianism she's relatively
moderate but on the on the right side
yeah but she's called they you know
these people in the media view her as
far right as possible and I'm like
you're ignoring the really crazy like
you know the right-wing authoritarian
and the right-wing libertarians are like
so dramatically further you know then
who are the right-wing authoritarians
right now we've you saw like Richard
Spencer yeah it's it's yeah so that's to
me it's like those guys are completely
they are actually completely irrelevant
they've is forced to be bubbled up into
these
verse Asians because people scream about
them all the time but it's like people
are people saying why don't you focus on
them why don't you focus on these it's
like they have no institutional power
everyone knows it's right to ignore
these terrible ideas I don't need to
amplify these ideas
I like the parts of the right that are
more libertarian and more small
government and anti-authoritarian but I
see no influence with that group of
people yeah and honestly it's it's crazy
to me how how much when I talked about
Britney Pettibone and the Wikipedia
thing they when when I when I went to
look at a Wikipedia page it said she was
a white supremacist anti-semite neo-nazi
and all these other really crazy things
and I'm like whoa like she sounds crazy
but because they were challenging me
yeah I'm like I started checking the
sources on this page
and sure enough guess what they were
moved a bunch of those claims because
they were unfounded there are people who
are weaponizing information and and
character assassinating people Richard
Spencer is a white nationalist who is
you know I've put him I would put him in
the in the top right Thorat Aryan
leaning towards authoritarian leaning
towards the right wing but he soon he
really wants the government to come in
and change immigration immigration
policies potentially get people out of
the country like I yeah I you know I
don't I I don't want to have this before
reflect on the things he said publicly
but I've talked to him about it and I
would definitely say based on my private
conversations with it like I interviewed
him I never ended abusing the interview
just because it it was during the
inauguration and there was a bunch of
breaking news that happened and it just
kind of fell off but yeah he's he's he's
authoritarian right but I wouldn't say
he's the most extreme Authority and
right person I've ever met yet he is
painted out to be that I think that's
actually dangerous when people say that
Richard Spencer is the epitome of evil
I'm like there's more it gets worse you
know like yeah I don't agree with his
opinions I think he's in a spot that's
like it's it's it parallels mine you
just an other litter on the other side
of what I believe like but it goes
further than Richard Spencer and when
you act like he's where it ends you
ignore that their actual insane like
hardcore right-wing authoritarian who
are buying guns yeah who are committing
crimes
you know so you're traveling everyone a
Nazi might be short-sighted very
dangerous when Richard Spencer is the
guy who stands in a street corner and
you punch him in the face
you're acting like the worst there is is
Richard Spencer when in reality they're
like enclaves of sovereign citizens with
guns who like refuse to get pulled over
or pay taxes and you know it gets pretty
fringe yeah it's pretty crazy but like
yeah like we're saying the Overton
Window ice shifted the point where we
look at somebody who simply says I'm you
know Cassandra Fairbanks who questions
not even immigration just just terrorism
and and illegal immigration and she's
called far-right yeah and I'm like she's
not no which I always think is hilarious
because they there are plenty of videos
of Obama before he became president
talking about why we have to protect our
borders and things with immigrants and
all that stuff and there's videos of
Bill Clinton saying he exact almost the
exact same things yeah Trump said with
you know the language is a little
different in Trump has a weird effect
and all that but almost the exact same
thing when you look at the you can view
Google search the Pluto compass and look
at where people have placed American
politicians and most of them fall
somewhere in the authoritarian right
it's not extreme authoritarian right but
it's in that spectrum I think Obama was
just just north of the barrier into
authoritarian and just right of center
yeah so people look at Obama and say
that he's like a liberal guy and it's
like sure but you know he is on the
spectrum he is on the right side right
and he's a little bit towards
authoritarian meaning he was more okay
with state power exactly and I mean if
you're president I think that's what's
going to happen in the United States
right but you know America is all about
the free you know the free market and
and we have limited regulations and
taxes relative to a lot of countries
when I was in Sweden they said the
United States doesn't have a left they
have a right and a further right that's
it and when you look at the political
compass where we place our politicians
like yeah that's that's I would I would
say that's relatively accurate yeah Jill
Stein though falls in the libertarian
lift all right well I did the political
compass about a year ago and I'm not
gonna say the results right now but I'm
gonna do it again and then we'll do a
video I'll just do a live video on it
with no yeah no editing or anything and
just put that narrative all like far
right oh man it's gonna be off the
charts is big enough to come up with a
new color quadrant or something for them
it's it's it's it's so crazy because I
to the video with luke rudkowski from we
are change where you know i talked about
this with him and then he said i want to
do the test too and he is center-right
libertarian like our opinions are almost
the same just a little bit different I
tend to view aye aye I believe that
there is a need for regulation in a lot
of areas but not crazy with it so I'm
only center-left and then Luke is kind
of like I don't know regulation gets bad
because a government gets too powerful
so I lean a little to the right yeah in
that case I probably lean a little
closer to him but I've shifted a little
bit but that kind of stuff but that's
the point single-payer health care
that's I'm presentable Paris I'll push
you really far left it will because
right yeah right I know I was at a
libertarian thing at the students for
liberty and in Maryland I gave a speech
and I was telling him about some of my
positions and I said it's great because
I know you guys are okay with agree to
disagree and I am for single-payer
health care and they booed me but then
all started laughing it's like it was
like yeah all right then they were all
and the people were kind of like
jokingly heckling me like yeah give it
some time Dave you'll come around on
this and I was like that's a beautiful
thing I could have stood there and been
like a faint oh you booed me like the
show's over yeah it's like we all got it
we don't have to agree on all this stuff
yeah alright so here's what I do we did
about an hour we're gonna do a super
chat Q&A I already know that most people
want to know about the beanie which
we've already talked about though every
there's a lot about what's going on
under the beanie why you wearing the
beanie it's LA it's hot all right guys
so that's we're we're to take literally
a 1 minute break I'm gonna refill the
water and then we'll be back we'll do
the super chat thing if you're on
patreon you guys get bumped up the queue
and and then we'll go from there right
one minute
[Music]
alright guys we're back I believe I
added a minute to the minute that I
literally said I was gonna take there
just bear with me okay here we go cuz
there's already a zillion things here
we'll start with super chat happy to see
you back here Tim what do you think
drives people to stop caring about
what's true that's a great question
because I ask you why you care about
what's true what about the other side of
that no I think everyone I don't think
people stop caring well people who stop
caring about what's true stopped came
out a lot of other things too and I feel
like when you read day after day bad
news when you start to wake up to the
fact that it's not that journalists are
evil it's just that they're just people
you know and so they're gonna get things
wrong there's a phenomenon where you
read a news to anyone about the last
time you read a news story and you think
it's true but when you read a news story
in which you are an expert you know it's
they're not true right so people start
to say you know what if I can't if if I
can't trust any of this I just don't
care anymore
and then whatever and then they they
they they just fan I think we get to the
point where people are so sick and tired
of being told that they're evil they're
racists that you know the Russia
conspiracy stuff with Trump and people
just finally like oh god I just don't
care anymore
like yeah and in a weird way that
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy too
because the apathy then the only way you
break people out apathy is with more
hysteria you don't break that apathy
with I'm gonna calmly tell you about no
that never happens
okay on patreon I asked you this before
but maybe you give me something that's
close Tim have you found anywhere in
your travels that is as free and fair as
America you know free and fair I guess
is a matter of perspective there's a lot
of people who are I'd say the people who
are far far left wouldn't love Sweden
except for the fact that you know I'll
so I'll say this I actually found Sweden
to be relatively racist and I mean I'm
not even kidding it's not it's about the
fact that there's an overwhelmingly
white majority that doesn't let
minorities work with their companies
while they'll claim they'll pay each
other in the back claiming if they're
not racist
mmm yeah they are I met white people who
I should say it's not necessarily racist
culture I met white people who spoke
Swedish who said they weren't Sweden
we didn't have to get jobs after two
years so I don't need to write I'd sweet
yeah so you answered the reverse
question give me something that's close
so I guess you're saying Sweden although
despite it no I
like a matter of opinion like a lot of
people on the left let the far left here
might be like Sweden's great
yeah and they might go there and just
sort of drink the kool-aid and and and
dance around thing that'd be this
fantastic because uh you know you know
I've got so much to rag on Sweden about
they export weapons that allows them to
have more social programs do you know
the Swedish comedian Aron flam by any
chance I've heard of yeah I had him on
the show about a month ago and he really
gave a really damaging assessment of
what has happened to Sweden and it
include the arms and all that all right
jump back to super chat for a second Tim
what do you think about countercultures
being co-opted by far left politics it
seems like anything remotely artistic
and fringe is overpopulated by far left
ideas asking based on your past so I
don't know what that's referring it may
be like growing up with like the an
Turkish I suppose but I feel like
everything comes and goes in waves you
know there was a period where the
country was significantly more
conservative in patriotic you know
nationalists and then the wave happens
where then it switches to the left then
the the beatnik the the rebels the
anarchist start becoming more more
palatable because they're challenging
the authority I think it has to do with
you know whenever there's a problem it's
the authority's fault mm-hmm so then
people will start becoming very very
left and then problems with Authority
rise and then people on the right are
like they're the problem and then it
just kind of taeju it back and forth
yeah yeah well that's the funny thing
it's like yes if the right started going
completely bananas right now on free
speech which I care about more than
anything else I would be criticizing
them yeah at the moment it just doesn't
seem to be this is a good one from
patron did Snowden go too far or not far
enough in his whistleblowing um I don't
I don't have a for or against if you
have Snowden I think he he published a
lot of information that was really
important we learned about a bunch of
illegal programs however snowed by
Snowden's own admission he didn't read
the documents that he took so it's not
whistleblowing it's just leaking in
which case there were several I think I
think it might have been John Oliver who
did the interview with him and it's a
surprising because I'm not a huge fan of
John Oliver but he said the New York
Times made a mistake when they publish
from the documents that they
accidentally had unredacted information
and at which none was like yeah that
stuff happens but then you know Oliver
said do you bear responsibility mm-hmm
did you read the document before you
leaked it and he goes I didn't and he
goes then this is your fault isn't it
and Snowden said I'm probably mixing up
a little bit about something we're
snowed and like you know owned up saying
like yeah you're right so I think the
issue is known is very complicated
because to me a whistleblower someone
who says I've identified a program where
programs that are illegal and this
information needs to get out versus just
taking tens of thousands of documents
and being like here you go right yeah so
potentially he did I mean we sort of hid
this in the first hour but potentially
he did something more dangerous because
even though you you're for the freedom
of information we don't know what all
the repressions are it's kind of like I
guess the issue there is it's it's
always important of a risk assessment to
we want to we want to look to the past
and the present to predict the future so
when it comes to leaking information
it's important that you know what
information you're leaking it it's a
challenge right the the more far-right
libertarian people are very much like
all information should be available
borders or fake things like that and I'm
kind of just like there's a lot to
consider and I'm not smart off to figure
it out so when I look at snowed and I
say him leaking out a bunch of
information that he didn't read presents
a pandora's it's kind of worms right but
at the same time we learned about a
bunch of illegal programs that we needed
to know about so it's it's not they're
bad it's just another such a great
example of why being intellectually
honest can create you problems on both
sides other people are gonna hear you
say that about you say he's selling
Snowden out in the serve your eyes
completely backroom yeah this is a good
one because I think it sort of
encompasses where we both are sort of
what do you think the difference between
left libertarian and right libertarian
is uh it's kind of its kind of weird
because when I look at the compass I
actually feel like far left libertarian
and far far right authoritarian don't
necessarily exist in it in a sense like
far left libertarian is less about
capitalism and more about a bunch of
hippies sitting in a circle and talking
about the best way to move forward and
agreeing to do work in exchange
whereas far-right is kind of like let
the system build itself the free market
will take care of it
and so it's kind of like before the left
you go there's more of a centralization
of decision-making mm-hmm
for me left libertarianism is kind of
like you can't force anybody to do
anything but we all need to agree on
what we should do
yeah whereas the far right is kind of
like let us do our thing and the market
will take care of it just people
sanctions will so basically you think
that so far left the only real
difference then is just the degree of as
we talked about before that you might be
more okay with a little more government
regulation on climate or something where
your friend you mentioned would be a
little less a little yeah and then like
the far the far far left libertarian is
actually the bottom left is anarchy yeah
where you know anarchy means without
authority and without our key authority
and that's basically where all decisions
are made by committee yeah you know
everyone comes together sits down and
tries to come to a decision I that seems
like it would work that's why I'm not a
you know I grew up very much like with
the anarchists yeah we really believed
that through conversation and that works
in a small community yeah but when
you've got a 300 million people it just
absolutely does not work so the reason
I'm sort of like center-left libertarian
is that authoritarianism violently
forcing people to do things or coercing
them through some kind of manipulation
or emotional force of some sort that's
just pain and suffering I'm not cool
with yeah but then I'm closer to the
middle because it's kind of like you
know we do need a market that can help
us compete and evolve but we need to
make sure doesn't go out of control
mm-hmm you know if you look at what what
Bayard Bayer has done Monsanto Dow
Chemical all these really horrifying
things they fight about in the past we
need to make sure look yeah it's a great
discussion that could be had there yeah
so you have the fear of those companies
going on unregulated or someone who
would be more libertarian right or left
Knight Arian would be saying well I'm
afraid of the government doing that so
but that's a great space to have the
exchange of ideas I had an argument with
this really famous Ana and an Kafka
anarcho-capitalist who told me that no
matter what happens he thinks the market
will take care of it and I'm like let me
just start naming some things like Union
Carbide the Bhopal disaster Deepwater
Horizon and I'm like the market did not
take care of the take care of this
companies continue to exist doing these
things Monsanto continued continues to
exist doing these things and I don't
know why shrug I guess yeah but at least
there's a conversation to be healthy
like you can understand the fear comes
from a different ones fear in government
more in ones bearing business more I
mean I think it's already please to that
but the reason I'm in the middle both
are right the monopolization of power is
the problem well said well said all
right back onto patreon do you struggle
at times to report the truth when it
means somebody you like their beliefs
will take a hit no I was uh this is
funny cuz I did a video and the the the
the opening card says celebrating with
the proud boys mm-hmm and that was not
to be mean that I was celebrating with
them it was like it was just meant to be
like the people were yeah you know but
during this this event which at which I
filmed like they're hazing and
everything one of the guys leaving the
some guy leaving a bar started yelling
that you're all like fascist white
supremacists so then one of the dudes
hanging out the proud boys I don't know
if he was a proud boy started yelling at
him and then they these two guys chase
after him full speed so I ran after
filming and then the guy gets in it like
the the guy who was starting the fight
get in his car and driving away flicking
them off the proud boys are yelling at
him and then one of them turns around
sees me filming and says the hell are
you doing whose side are you on
and I laugh and was like not your horse
that was like I was like dude I'm a
journalist I'm here to film what happens
and he was like stop turn that camera
off and I'm like I was like dude chill
out nothing happened a bunch of guys
walk down the street yelling at each
other it's not reportable yeah but the
fact remains like if you gotta do I told
the other guys when I asked me what
happened
and I was like if I was about to break
out and they were like Oh for real and I
was like yeah he got mad I was filming
but I'll tell you what you guys like I'm
not on your side I'm not on anyone's
side if fight breaks out I'm gonna film
it and they were like yeah alright I'm
like you knows it it's not about liking
somebody or not it's like you know it's
just about look if people say these
these guys are you know doing bad things
I'm not gonna lie for them know just
what it is what it is
that's what it is oh this is very
important from super chat thoughts on
Pepe the Frog post-election oh I don't
know is it it's it's crazy to me how
serious everyone has taken Pepe the Frog
to the point where I'm I I don't want to
say this is true but I feel like most
people who show the Pepe the Frog don't
take it seriously yeah I think that's
absolutely true let's say 90% of the
people
roasting Pepe the Frog even in the okay
sign and milk and ice cream yeah and the
people on the left are like pulling
their hair out
yeah the hope that's the whole point of
pulling the whole point I'm not saying I
love it but like I get it here here
there have it they're just trying to
mess with people here's what this this
article did was you're not the races
that you need to worry about let's put
it that this article that called me
alright one of the things they said was
in the photo you can see people making
the okay hand sign which is associated
with Pepe the Frog a symbol deal I hate
symbol by the anti-defamation league
yeah you see what they did there yeah
the okay symbol is yes technically
affiliated with Pepe the Frog but this
was the Trump hand sign because he
doesn't he talks yeah and it became a
meme and then they added this to Pepe
and then he claimed because it was
associated he was able to ward a
sentence accusing this of being a white
sperm his hand gesture instead of saying
the ADL said the okay sign is not a hate
symbol he said the okay symbol is
associate with Pepe the Frog yeah which
is a hate symbol these yeah it looks
like the ADL it's like man after all the
legitimate grievances that people have
had to fight through of Holocaust and
programs and all of the little herbs
true slaughters and murders work now
we're going like this which I know now
blows well the ADL said that's it they
they debunked that this is not hate some
yeah no no but they did say the Pepe was
a hates exactly I'm like come on guys
the cartoon frog used by a bunch of kids
on the Internet
I'm pretty sure that the average person
who was in Auschwitz if they would have
eventually had to have been realizing
that sixty years later after surviving
that the Frog was gonna be the biggest
problem would probably I mean it's just
it's so stupid
oh this I'm glad someone's asking this
because people have been asking me this
super chat what are your thoughts on the
Julius Caesar play interruption
disruption of free speech or political
stunts uh it was a political stunt yeah
I believe they were accused of buying
the domain free Laura a couple hours
before doing the event so I think they
knew was going to happen I read
somewhere that
this play they just depict the president
and they've done Obama in the past
mm-hmm I don't know if that's true but I
don't know
look disrupting the play I I'd neither
agree with or disagree with what I will
say is to the people who are freaking
out saying like how would you describe
the play I'm like oh that's peaceful
protest like I'm I'm pretty much okay
with people peacefully protesting like
you're getting allowed you're being
noisy sure it's so much better than
throwing explosives and bashing people
over the head right at the same time the
play was free speech it it it's a it's a
conundrum I'm a moderate okay it's like
I see I see both sides and yeah
ultimately the most important thing is
that both events are our peaceful
protests and so I'm kind of just like
yeah you guys say your piece yeah so
I'll go a little further than you on
that one so I have obviously no problem
with the play in and of itself we do
unfortunately live in a time where these
things being put out there do seem to be
affecting people's actions in a violent
way which is a problem but it's free
speech to put on the play of course if
somebody wants to give you the theater
to do it and sell tickets and all that
the disruptors have their right to free
speech so they can do it but then you
have consequences they get a wrestling
speech UI that will be arrested or
kicked out and absolutely that should
happen I don't think the protesters
should just be able to get on stage you
know the the the exchange we have of
free speech is not that you can only use
your silence someone else's speech you
will suffer the consequences so I am a
hundred percent okay with these people
or whatever the odds are related you
know whatever the theaters policies are
if you disrupt you're gonna be kicked
out look I've been in comedy clubs well
I was always okay with heckling when I
was doing stand-up but I've been in many
comedy clubs where they kick people out
and heckling is sort of understood to be
part of comedy yeah so it's up to the
theater and then if there are local laws
I'm completely ultimately I'm like if
the extent of your protest is running up
on stage and yelling for 30 seconds and
then you get removed and arrested and
things move on yeah
the inherent problem with that though of
sort of okaying that is that then it
will just start happening everywhere
every Broadway show that you ever go to
someone's gonna be aggrieved about
sincerity
what's that bail up the security no no
but it'll still happen if people just
know that they're gonna every show you
can go to Beauty there's
upset a beast but you know some ugly guy
let me say this because I was talking
some people about this when the Hamilton
cast you know made the statement to to
to my pence yeah a lot of people the
right freaked out and I'm like that's
the kind of protest we want yeah you
they took a couple minutes to say it's a
their bit nonviolent put them on the
spot
III think pence could have owned up to
that and just said I will do my best
that's only you know it didn't he
basically do that though it's something
like something like yeah right that's
the thing like that's what you want like
he he went there to this place hopefully
to learn and to be around some New York
liberals and yeah well that's up so like
to me it was like he tried to do
something good
they then at the end use their free
speech to hopefully have a teachable
moment but it was like everybody was
then immediately screaming at how racist
Pence's or whatever or anti-gay and it's
like guys that's not how you get people
on your side you yeah who's this as a
teachable moment hopefully he saw some
tolerance heard what they said but
everybody I actually I was like that's
that's pretty cool you're like when I
see an tyfa bashing people over the
heads I don't like that's a problem darn
it supposed to that's a problem yeah
when I see everyone's Nazi it's a
problem when I see a bunch of people on
a stage say we just want you to do your
best represent all Americans I'm like I
agree with that that's pretty solid I
got I I agree you the president should
represent all Americans and do their
best and they're simply just talking
yeah okay well let me throw one in here
just for a second because we haven't
really talked about Russia what Trump
Russia is he a Russian agent yes or no I
think we learned that the answer was no
to that when the Comey testimonia know
the whole issue with that seems like was
that why would trump in my opinion did
not fire Comey over the Flynn stuff
because that conversation happened a
long time ago
it wasn't like sitting on this just
waiting for his moment to do it that
even Comey said this that the reason
Trump was probably angry was that Comey
would not confirm Trump wasn't under
investigation right so is now as soon as
that hearing ends then they announce
like Trump's being investigated for
obstruction and it's just like honestly
I'm just so tired of hearing this yeah
that's one thing like just never go I
think people have to accept so I'm fully
with you on that I think we love to
accept this is not going to stop the
plan is to impeach him I really believe
that I I plan coat you know half media
half
the Democrat land is just we're going to
try to impeach him that or or will waste
the entire four years of his
administration yep distractions to do it
okay I agree yeah all right one more in
super chat that will jump back into
patreon so we are answering questions
Tim's answering questions I should say
on super chata patreon Tim what are your
thoughts about influences of alternative
media and public in turn on influence
stri that again what are your thoughts
about the influences of alternative
media and public internet forums such as
4chan in today's society 4chan is one of
the most powerful and terrifying things
I have ever witnessed in my life
they found a cabin in the woods yeah
based on like the direction of the Sun
yeah they found a flag pointed up at the
sky based on the star maps and the and
the planes flying overhead that was the
Shia book thing yeah yeah Wow then is
scary like it's not like scary in the
sense of like they're coming to get you
scary or scary of like that is an
overwhelming it's a supercomputer these
these people on 4chan have done such I
made a video about this they've
convinced the media this is a hate
symbol they they're like these they just
decide to do it and they know how to do
it it's it's it's almost the I'm gonna
veto called 4chan has become too
powerful mm-hmm it's yeah I've talked a
lot of these I I should go on 4chan a
long time ago I think you know a lot of
the hacker community people did and I've
talked to some of these these these kids
who are on there and one of them told me
never underestimate the power of
millions of lonely men and I was like he
you know he basically told me that he
lost his job
and he lives in a kind of like a
semi-rural Alexa Bourbon area and so he
just was in the computer and he found a
community that likes to put you know
make jokes and have fun and everything
silly and they when they find a project
to to take up they do it no and if
that's locating a flag in the middle of
the desert by the sound of frogs
croaking or finding a cabin based on the
direction of the Sun when you when you
get thousands of people all working
towards it that is a supercomputer no
it's crazy it's a particularly dangerous
super gear because it's got a lot of
computing power and a lot of human power
that's like the ultimate but that's t2
III you know so I wonder I mean the a
4chan was the birthplace of the
anonymous hacked
activism and they've done a lot of
really historical powerful stuff it's
it's it's not good or evil it's just raw
humanity functioning as a big machine
like it it's it's amazing hmm Tim have
you ever filed a Freedom of Information
Act request no but I had this really
cool idea you know where I would take a
couple of my friends and we would FOIA
our FBI files and then have a contest to
see whose was bigger
we never did it but you never did it
yeah okay all right another on patreon
Tim have you research media corruption
and if so ever found a more corrupt time
period than right now in the USA or the
world III haven't but I mean more
corrupt I think it's relative and it's
also your definition of corrupt is it
corrupt in the sense that they're evil
people who are manipulating it or is it
corrupt in the sense that it's decayed
to a point where it's just trash mm-hmm
in my opinion we were - sighs the pass
I keep hearing people say like Oh
Woodward and Bernstein and I'm like yeah
but they did the whole anonymous or same
thing - I think we need to realize is
that culture changes and that the
standards for what is true acceptable on
the Internet is dramatically different
from what was you know acceptable and
true for the newspapers and television
in the past yeah so corrupt mmm-hmm
different yeah all right super chat you
just answered this one but Tim do you
agree that Trump colluded with Russia we
got a no on that one here's a good one
right because I get this all the time
super chat advice for Millennials that
want to stand up for free speech and
rational thought but fear the backlash
from peers like how did you get to the
point where you said I'm gonna do this
yet I guess it's just a matter of
conviction just you gotta go do it one
of the big challenges with the free
speech stuff is that these free speech
rallies are all Trump supporters and
I've talked to Trump supporters and I
said if you want to be taken seriously
and get some liberal speakers in
Berkeley at one of their events a woman
came up and asked to speak on the on the
megaphone and they were like are you are
you a trump supporter he said no and a
bunch people were like no no but then
all sudden this big biker dude with like
a spiked helmet goes no this is a free
speech event she can speak and then
everyone started clapping and cheering
yeah
and then she basically just said you
know think of the children protect the
children I usually like I know you're
all here to do your thing and just keep
in mind there's a school next door and
then everyone
and they let her do it they let these
intolerant yeah but I think the main
issue with free speech is you know I've
talked to Trump supporters I said you
know what you need to do I was like the
left needs to do a free speech rally and
the right needs to do an anti-racism
rally because in San Bernardino just
this anti Sharia thing I talked to the
Trump supporters I said are you guys
opposed to fascism and they're all like
yes I said so you're anti fascist and
they're like yeah but not like those
guys I'm like I get it then I go to the
ante for guys I'm like you guys opposed
Sharia law and they're like well yeah
and I'm like okay just like just like
they do and they go yeah but they're
bigots and I'm like at the core guys
agree with each other so I think you
know if you got some people on the Left
hold a free speech rally they've got
some people on the right to do it like
an opposition to racism rally yeah there
you go
listen I would love to headline a left
free speech rally or a lot of really
great any free speech group on a campus
that is a left-leaning one and speak I
only get invited to the right one so but
I at your point but I think there's a
growing community of people who are left
kind of like us know that agree with
free speech and where we get along with
the Trump supporters is on issues of
free expression and I think that's why
we get dubbed you're like all right
simply because we agree with them on
some things
yeah and then the far far left people
don't agree with with free speech so I
think there's a there's a there's a
large group of people who are like
center-left liberals who don't agree
with Trump in his policies but agree
with free speech and would attend a
rally and would put it on but there
needs to be leadership to make it happen
are you listening people make it happen
superjet do you think there's a way of
mainstream media regaining the public's
trust or are they too far gone that's a
good one we cannot hit it before I don't
think it's an issue of whether they
trustworthy or not I think it's an issue
of who people choose to trust and you
know more than half of people say they
get their news from Facebook at this
point so am I gonna trust Anderson
Cooper guy in a suit on TV was million a
millionaire or am I gonna trust my good
friend who says trust me man this is
true I don't know my friend he's he's
saved my butt a couple times he'll fix
my car and bought me lunch Anderson
Cooper was he done for me that's my
buddy yeah is that the other part that
people know us in a different way you
know it mean like yeah I had I had two
little no cards here I didn't even look
at them once we've just talked
you've revealed things about yourself I
reveal things about myself that just by
being human yeah just by being human
we've allowed people to give us give us
that trust which maybe will fail them on
one day but like we've allowed them to
just get in on that I met a thing you
tweet at me actually I I've had people
with like three followers starting
salting me and I just tweet right back
at I'm like I'm just I'm I don't know
you know it's there's that's the power
of Twitter that we talked about a long
time ago that celebrities were now more
likely to interact with their fans but
for me I'm not like a celebrity I just
have someone that people start they keep
following me on Twitter because I do
this work but I still use Twitter the
same way I've always used it you tweet
at me I tweet back obvious like
sometimes I get too many notifications
but I've gone on the huge tirades with
like just like you know random people I
don't I don't know I don't feel like I'm
above or below or anything I just feel
like I'm on Twitter and you can tweet at
me and I'll tweet back yeah my ability
to respond is getting I just don't get
to take my time in it and especially if
you're just an anonymous troll and again
I get trolling I like trolling but if
you're just an anonymous person
endlessly spewing hey to me it's like I
am okay with the block okay I'm okay
with it if I have the time I give
everyone the time of day yeah not gonna
discriminate you can you can you can
call me names and salt me and I'll sell
tweet at you oh good one patron
who's your mainstream media hero that
seems to make the biggest strides
towards telling the truth I suspect you
don't have many heroes yeah now Klee but
you got any I mean give me somebody is
there anyone because we both get asked
this all the time like huh I started
mentioning you and that I'm like you
guys know this tympole guy
I appreciate that yeah in the mainstream
media what do I trust I have no idea I
know I know some journalists that
there's there's a you know the first
thing comes to mind is a sky from Occupy
Wall Street who now is a photographer up
in Portland I just saw em for the first
time in five years in will Gaghan and he
is a lefty occupy kind of guy and he was
at the Portland rally and he flat out
said the only time I've ever seen
violence was from the ante for guys
people in black bloc and I was like oh
but you're like you're a lefty occupy
dude he goes yeah I'm like do you think
the Trump people are racist and he's
like oh I think there's a lot of hate
speech over there for sure and I'm like
but you're saying an TiVo's finding us
yeah
like I can trust you yeah you did it you
know yeah super chat such a good idea
about the yin-yang rally I want credit
for that name so I guess the the the
idea like let's just come up with some
like you know but I've taught you pulled
it off I've talked to Trump supporter
said why don't you guys do an anti
racism rally and there and they said
they don't exclude people yeah and I'm
like okay III don't want to be an
organizer and like actually suggest they
do it my question is when they tell me
they oppose in in in Berkeley the Baked
Alaska was trying to talk to people on
the other side the some of the people
chanting at them and one of them started
chanting no KKK you know no Trump no KKK
no fascist USA and then baked actually
said yeah no KKK and then they looked at
him more like what he's like I'm with
you and they were like oh and then he
fist bumped him yeah and I'm like well
why can't you have that rally you know
what you actually bring together the
people who are like moderate center
right center left who are kind of like
okay we agree that racism is bad
we agree that free speech is good and
doesn't matter what your political
faction is it's tough to gin up sane
people yeah you know I get the same
people really G end up they have other
things to do they like you know going
out and playing sport and having sex and
eating and what and whatever else it is
yeah okay how do you feel on Facebook
when someone posts something and the
criticism is the poster allegedly stayed
silent
on a similar topic that's a good one
because I get that a lot
you know like oh if I if there's one
story if I happen to not be I'm trying
to get on Twitter for the weekend and
something happens to my guy you see
Ruben you didn't tweet about that oh I
was actually on a plane for six hours
and hey there's right right right the
other day someone tweeted all of the
conservative voices staying silent on
the the London attack where the van hit
the Muslims yeah are showing their
hypocrisy or something and the
interesting thing I noticed was cuz I
tweeted a couple things about it because
for me I'm like mine she was violence
right I don't care
stop being violent against people who
are not being violent but when the
Manchester tech happens when the London
Westminster Bridge and all stuff happens
my Twitter feed is nothing but talking
about it mmm-hmm
the van attack happened no one was
talking about it and even right now the
Trump supporter was stabbed nine times
no one is talking about it so there's
there's an issue one is it really that
you won't talk about an issue of it's
the other side or is it that there's no
conversation there means when you're
talking to a wall that's that's the
challenge for me I'm kind of like I just
tweeted violence begets violence you
know we hear about these terror attacks
from these these these crazy Islamic
Islamists and then what happens is some
guy gets angry and drives a van into
some Muslims coming out of a mosque yeah
like people just it's a cycle of revenge
retribution and it just makes people
hate each other more yeah so it's so
interesting how the the knee-jerk
reaction to immediately something
happens and we all have to share all our
opinions on it and I'm even trying even
as someone that does what I do I'm
trying to scale back on that a little
bit yeah because I just think it just
starts feeding this monster and when
this thing happened when the truck got
driven into the into the mosque I
happened to be traveling all day I was
on a plane with no I fired him by Wi-Fi
intentionally so I didn't know about it
till I got off the plane I look at my
Twitter I saw something happening I was
like I need to be off on a Sunday like I
need to have like some clarity and I
happened to get home like my dog was
sick I basically was at the Animal
Hospital half the night and I ended up
just retweeting a someone that I do
trust on this but I knew that there was
gonna be a certain amount of people a
guy you see he didn't I was just like I
didn't want to get in the frame and it
could have been any other specific
incident anyway why do you choose the
beanie and not another hat I never I've
been very conservative here with the
beanie thing ah no no you know the funny
thing is people Eve always ask me about
it and I've got I was thinking about it
I have photos from when I was 16 I'm
wearing the beanie like I've just it's a
skateboard a thing yeah you go to a
skate park and 30 or 40 percent will be
wearing beanies I saw a guy wearing a
wool sweater and a beanie on some in the
summer and I laughed because I'm like
people say the same thing about my
beanie in the summer you know what you
want to know okay first you wanna hear
the gross truth I guess so
it soaks up all my sweat and when I'm
running around during like conflicts and
stuff it's literally like a sweat band I
can't wear a band because they look
silly right so I wear a beanie because
it fits my skateboard kind of style but
the big secret for one I've always had
some kind of hat I used to wear
hippy hippy beanie visor things they're
called but after Occupy Wall Street
I had the former marketing director for
Puff Daddy telling me that the beanie
was my character and not taking it off
that's really it he said that he was
like I was reading a magazine man I saw
you in and I'm like this beanie guy
yeah the beanie guy and then he was like
if you ever do anything make sure like
you you keep the beanie it's who you are
so I can make sure denta file and I was
like okay honestly I wasn't gonna have
you on the show if you had walked in
here without the beanie no no I had a
very clear who's that guy yeah
beanie come on we're not gonna do this
without a beanie but I'll say this the
fact that you asked about it yeah the
fact that's become a meme proves that
it's like who's the point I'm kind of
like it's become you know like DeRay
McKesson wears a vest and Reagan wears a
flannel like care you know you have
something identifiable about you I
suppose I guess I wear a jacket right
yeah yeah Tim what happens if Islamist
extremists and left-wing extremists
combine their efforts to silence the
rest of us and then realize that they're
truly ideological enemies who wins at
that point is called a narc Islam I'm
joking oh you know I hear so many stupid
terms all day long I was like ah man
here we go another one heck Islam that
is a great question though about
intersect actually there's a there's
forums where I see anarchists I
shouldn't say in Turkish because the
true anarchist doesn't believe in using
authority on somebody else but they're
like far-left communists who are talking
about looking into Islamist doctrine for
advice and this is what I'd say this is
on the reddit community the anarchism
commute they were talking about
researching Islam for their you know
communist communism and
anarcho-syndicalist like factions and
beliefs and that to me while like I
bring up because I'm sure a lot people
gonna go oh my god like you know these
two factions are uniting I'm kind of
like true anarchists or totally chill
and peaceful and the overall majority of
Muslims are just like chilling minding
their own business
but then you get to the argument of like
what percentage of these groups are
violent and that's something like I'm
not smart enough to to assert but if any
violent faction joins forces with any
other violent faction yeah as something
to worry about yeah and I'll say this
the terror attacks have been happening
in Europe are many of them have been
from anarchists I don't know how many I
was researching terrorism for a video I
did it just a few weeks ago but there
were like letter bombs sent to the IMF
headquarters by Greek anarchists hmm so
in Africa in the Middle East
there are anarchist attacks do you think
it's fair to say that if let's say this
strange leftist Islamist alliance
actually won the battle of ideas and
started taking over it would be far
worse for the social justice people
eventually than the Islamists right well
let me like the social justice people we
would be almost impossible for them to
turn against the Islamists at that point
but the Islamists that would have some
plans in place to get rid of the other
people let me get a bit semantics
getting into the semantics yeah true
anarchists yeah who follow Islam would
probably be super cool people yeah they
would disagree with using force against
other people they would disagree with
with terror and they would probably
chill in the corner and say let's have a
conversation cuz yeah that's true
anarchy and I think that sounds pretty
great the the joke is actually communist
Lomb there's a there's like a video
where someone's making fun of Glenn back
and then he's like oh honey you like
right sit on a board and that's like you
know communism is well they people say
it's actually like left libertarian it's
actually been implemented as an
authoritarian route and when you combine
that with extremism regardless of
whether it's Islamic or or any other
religion yeah then we got authoritarians
who are following a fundamentalist
doctrine that's terrifying yeah that's a
that's a bad combo all right we got
about 15 minutes left we're doing this
on super chat and on patreon Q&A with
Tim Poole I've been in the mainstream
media for a few years now any tips on
breaking free and going at it alone
about the save your money because you're
gonna be sleeping in a closet and you're
gonna be broke here's here's the crazy
thing I've had people say to me Tim how
do I do what you do and I say just go do
it and so but to be a bit more serious
someone said like but I can't afford to
fly around the world and do these crazy
things you know the one of the some of
the first stuff that I've ever covered
was 20 other bus ticket I was in
Virginia
I was at my brother's place Occupy Wall
Street happened I bought a $20 China bus
ticket with there's a cellphone and a
backpack and I went up and you started
tweeting not because I expected to gain
followers or to make a career out of it
it was just something I wanted to do and
I was willing to just drop everything
and go do it but you know what I hear
all the time oh but what about my
apartment and then I'd have to remind
people I didn't have one mmm I was
sleeping at the Occupy I was sleeping in
the park and even when I started working
for Vice I was crashing on my buddy's
sofa saving all of my money because I
knew that at any moment this could all
stop and then I'd have to have my own
resources to do my thing yeah so the
question becomes what's more important
to you having an apartment and a nice
job where you can go out on the weekends
nuclear buddies or would you rather
travel the world fly to exotic locations
and cover events that are changing the
world if that means your panic and have
health care you probably won't be eating
very good food you'll be eating rice and
beans a lot and you're probably asleep
on someone's floor most of the time yeah
you know pick your you know which one do
you want
it's funny when I think back of all the
things that I was doing when I was a
struggling comic and in New York and the
odd jobs I had and standing out on
street corners in the freezing cold to
hand out tickets so I could perform for
free and I ate literally almost nothing
but tuna for a year because my friend
worked at a distributor they had a lot
of to know so I'm most likely gonna die
of murder I think I mean when I think
about that it's like I don't know how
the hell I did it but I always say the
same thing to people say if you like
what I do do it yourself like if you
know like go if you want to do it then
start a YouTube channel and if you hate
me that's the other thing if you hate me
if you think I'm a terrible interviewer
you don't like the questions I asked
start a interview show do it bad to me
go to town you've got some trolls who
like make videos about you yeah it's
like there you go awesome like okay did
you but go wonderful free speech man uh
Tim speaks about a new network idea is
Dave gonna get in on it oh so I started
a web browser started web site sub verse
that and that awhile ago and I was you
know this is after I left fusion and I
was thinking like maybe I should just
you know work with my brother and try
and start something yeah is the most
difficult thing ever
trying to get people who want to write
having no money and then what ends up
happening is people slow start losing
interest
because you know a lot of people just
expect you know an instant return on
whatever the work they're doing and I'm
so I will say now is the idea with sub
verse is to try and convince people to
be their own journalists to do their own
YouTube Twitter whatever and then we
will aggregate as like a having
contributors will post their stuff it's
and take a while but it is being worked
on so it takes it's not it takes money
it takes technology it takes patience
and perhaps and I only have so many but
it's gonna say you seem like a busy guy
as it is super chat ever thought of
going to any one of the many quote black
graduations where people are willingly
segregating themselves and asking if
they're racist uh no well I mean yes I
thought about going but I wouldn't go
that if a group of people say like we
won't have a private event for our
specific group it's one thing if it's a
public institution like the Harvard
thing that people are talking about that
a lot people to understand is that it
was a private event organized by a
private group not Harvard if something
if there's public funding towards an
event like the evergreen college thing
right that's a state college right there
goes yeah if they say white people gotta
go I'm like now it's illegal like I mean
you can ask them to do it they're not to
do it and then if you get invited
because of it like you're crossing the
line
yeah but of a bunch of people of any
race are like we're gonna have a private
meeting to talk about our issues I'm
like that's America you know you're
allowed to have private events
yeah it's not it's not publicly funded
fair enough
Tim and Dave do you think that people
are now publicly reacting reacting to
each other based on what they are
reading online all day in other words
the violent and mean rhetoric we used to
think only happened on the internet is
now manifesting itself physically I
think the first video I did in this year
was that internet culture is now
becoming mainstream culture and I really
do believe it I'm starting to see it the
friendships that are breaking up even
family members that are being intolerant
of each other snipping biting I have my
facts you have your facts that this was
on it was really only online 3 years ago
and it really has bubbled up and it'll
only be 10 times worse in 10 years you
know that's the big conundrum of the
authoritarian versus libertarian
argument for a lot of people is that
when you have an authoritative broadcast
some where rich people control it and
dictate what the masses can see in here
that it can control things and and and
if they want to start or stop violence
they can do it then and then the inverse
that is with a libertarian system of
free information spread around people
just will start fighting each other and
there's no one who can stop it I have
friends who are actually authoritarian
left
I wouldn't put them in like the Stalin
bracket but they believe that you know
there need to be some control and what
people think in here because certain
ideas are dangerous oh if you let the
anti-vaxxers start spreading this
information then people stop taking
vaccinations and then we all get sick
and die therefore the government should
make X happen you know it's that that's
actually a pretty mainstream thought
though yeah you say like there are
plenty of celebs that were all you know
hating on was just Suzanne Somers or I
guess Alex Jones well yeah no but to
deviate from the anti Beck's thing to
talk about megyn kelly how dare she
interview Alex Jones his ideas should
not be shared the problem with that is
by coming out and saying you can't do
this
everyone hears that it's a Streisand
effect mm-hmm so that's why I subscribe
to a libertarian belief of like let the
bad ideas bounce around and eventually
the stupid ideas disappear whereas if
you try and challenge it you get a bunch
of kids being like well maybe you don't
want to get a vaccine right
I'll show you vac yeah exactly all right
Phil DeFranco starting a news program
looking for reporters what are your
thoughts uh I don't know if I don't know
if like I know of him but I mean I think
we all know each other right right right
yeah we go to VidCon in a couple days
and yeah you know I I don't know what it
is but coming from I came from like the
alternative alternative world when I
first started doing what I did live
streaming live streaming was nothing
mm-hmm got a bunch of attention for
doing it live shame started to get big
no one cared about news so I have never
been I have never had success at doing
anything and I'll put it this way me
going to VidCon is always felt like an
uphill battle where I'm not welcome
there
yeah I am a moderate center-left news
personality in VidCon the biggest
YouTube convention has personalities a
talk or like real issues but you know
hey the guy who you know was one of the
founding members of I see news who's
traveled the world actually covered the
stuff in the alternative media space
pioneering livestream is not someone er
Able's that's not someone wearing
having that I've actually had an agent
of really like reputable agent say like
hey are you guys gonna have this guy
here and they were like we're not
interested so why do I still go to
VidCon I don't know because people are
there but you know I I don't know it's
it's their event yeah I don't need to be
involved okay I kind of feel the same
way I mean I know everybody's there I
you know you're here today because of
that I have sargon coming on later
because of that I know there's gonna be
some some hangouts maybe with some
people so I'm not I don't think I'm
gonna make it but if there's something
like cool going down off-site we just
let me know about that I'm gonna parties
and networking yeah what I really want
to do is interview people so I was able
to interview Chris Raygun yeah which was
that was cool yesterday and then maybe
I'll get to I did a video for Sargon's
channel and I got the sargon bump which
like I don't my channel for much subs
right I had a bird driver be like I saw
you on on Sargon's channel I was like
wow like this is oh so I'm definitely
grateful that you know he you know was
willing to put out my video on his
platform so maybe I'll get to
interviewer meet him yeah that's better
than the uber driver who's like ah I
know you you're an all right yeah
exactly
well I mean being on Sargon's channel
it's like yeah you're not supremacist I
love them
all right brother well it was a pleasure
doing this I have a feeling we're gonna
do many of these yeah I'm done I didn't
I didn't realize that was your second
third time guest or whatever I didn't my
friend Faisal Saitama tar who is a
freedom fighter for Western values
refugee from Iraq is number one uh uh
dad said a refugee from Lebanon who now
fights for freedom in Canada I think
he's also a three-time er okay yeah so
you're number three technically one of
the ones we did we got it was a test
show oh so we can consider I didn't
realize that this was anything you know
this is but I feel special I'm you
should have had a some balloons falling
yeah all right it was a pleasure
follow Tim on the Twitter at Tim cast
what's your direct YouTube youtube.com
slash Tim cast youtube.com slash Tim
cast and we'll be doing this with with
Sargon at what time does at 2 p.m.
Pacific which is 5 p.m. Eastern all
right later
you